[Musique]
elle a fait ses gammes à droite avec
Alain Madelin puis Alain Jupé désormais
membre de Renaissance elle occupe un des
postes les plus stratégiques à
[Musique]
l'Assemblée bonjour Marie gevenou
bonjour alors en 2017 quand vous êtes
arrivé ici à l'Assemblée vous aviez à
peine 40 ans je crois et vous aviez déjà
plus de 20 ans d'expérience de politique
quand la plupart de vos collègues de la
République en marche débutai tout juste
si l'on peut dire en politique on a
retrouvé des image de vous qui date de
1996 à l'époque vous étiez engagé au
sein du syndicat étudiant uni et vous
vous apprêtiez à rencontrer Jacques
shirac à Amien à 19 ans en première
année de droit elle s'est engagé à fond
pour le candidat Chirac elle aussi sera
du
déjeuner on va faire un bilan sur
l'orientation sur le le procès des
sélectifs qui est pas terrible terrible
à l'université on va parler de
l'insertion professionnelle on va parler
du statut d'étudiant et du statut social
alors quand on vous entend faire la
liste de tous les sujets que vous voulez
aborder avec JAC shirac à cette occasion
on sent que pas rempli la mission ouais
mais il y avait déjà ce côté très carré
très sérieux chez vous vous étiez pas là
pour pour aller faire des blagues avec
Jacques shirac quoi c'était oui oui mais
alors j'ai c'est amusant parce que le le
je crois que le déjeuner j'ai réussi à
lui dire qui j'étais et c'est pas all
plus lo si j'ai quand même à faire une
remarque voilà mais mais c'était quand
même impressionnant pour le président de
la République c'est vrai qu'on on se
mettait pas mal de pression moi c'était
mon mon premier engagement ça comptait
pour moi on m'envoyait déjeuner avec le
président de la République vous voilà la
sortie de du déjeuner sur le perron de
la préfecture c'est c'est la campagne
présidentielle de de Jacques Chirac qui
a déclenché votre premier engagement
vous avez soutenu sa campagne sauf que
vous définissez pas comme chirakienne
pourquoi parce que je crois que au fond
ah je vais le dire très
façon très franche je pense que j'ai été
rapidement un peu déçu euh de de de
l'action qu'il avait qu'il avait mené et
puis maintenant que j'ai vieilli je me
rends compte que les choses sont moins
simples et qu'au fond déçus c'est
probablement trop fort mais à l'époque
oui je me considérais pas comme comme
shiraken j'étais j'étais plus sensible à
à la personnalité d'Allan Madelin oui et
ça c'est à partir de de 1999 oui mais
mais en 95 il est membre du gouvernement
euh etin Jupé et il est ministre de
l'économie et des finances et il
démissionne rapidement après avoir été
nommé et j'avais à l'époque estimé que
au fond c'était la preuve d'une forme de
de cohérence avec ses convictions et ça
ça m'avait assez impressionné donc al
incarné la droite libéral à l'époque
vous avez milité dans son parti à partir
de
1999 vous avez d'ailleurs dirigé le le
Mouvement des Jeunes avec Madelin et
puis quand al la Madelin a intégré l'UMP
vous l'avez suivi et là c'est Alain Jupé
que vous avez rencontré il a été le
premier président de l'UMP sur le papier
vous étiez pas forcément fait pour pour
vous entendre et puis finalement ça
s'est bien passé il vous a fait
confiance euh comment vous expliquez que
que l'alchimie se soit bien faite entre
vous euh bah parce que Alain Jupé c'est
quelqu'un qui euh qui est très à
l'écoute euh contrairement à ce que
l'image peut passer euh peut laisser
penser de lui c'est quelqu'un qui est
très à l'écoute et euh et qu' a une
vraie considération pour la jeunesse
j'ai puobserver quand moi-même j'étais
jeune h et après j'ai pu
l'observer avec lui parce que j'ai
cheminé en fait assez assez longtemps
avecin Jup parce que j'ai commencé à à
je l'ai rencontré en 2002 vous l'avez
dit et j'ai fait sa campagne voilà
exactement j'ai fait sa campagne pour
les pour les primaires de de la droite
et du centre en
2016 et j'ai eu l'occasion d'observer
que avec les jeunes de 2016 don je
faisais plus partie il avait le même la
même écoute la même bienveillance et le
même intérêt au fond et donc c'était
pour quelqu'un de 25 26 27 ans je sais
plus quel âge j'avais précisément à
l'époque avoir un ancien Premier
ministre président de parti à l'époque
présidentiable qui s'intéresse à vous et
à votre point de vue au point de vue de
votre génération c'était pas très
difficile de du coup de bien s'entendre
avec lui et alors à l'UMP vous avez créé
puis présider le Mouvement des Jeunes
Populaires vous avez été la première
présidente des des Jeunes Pop vous y
avez côtoyé beaucoup de personnalités
que vous croisez aujourd'hui à
l'Assemblée dans les rendus RN de LR de
la majorité présidentielle je peux citer
Franck alisio Sébastien Chenu Aurélien
Pradier Virginie dub muler Aurore berger
Gérald daranin Benjamin Hadad et encore
je crois qu'il y en a d'autres pas mal
ça veut dire que c'est quand même
c'était quand même une bonne école de la
politique les Jeunes Pop ah oui c'était
une très d'abord les mouvements de
jeunesse de façon générale c'est une
école de la politique certains disent du
VI moi oui c'était la phase de mitteran
sur le Mouvement des Jeunes Socialistes
c'est l'école du VIS oui mais alors nous
on nétait pas des Jeunes Socialistes
donc moi j'ai pas le sentiment d'avoir
vécu dans l'école du vis non c'est
vraiment c'était très formateur moi j'
j'en retire d'abord une bande de copains
qui sont pas forcément les noms que vous
ave avez cité même si j'ai des affection
pour certains des des gens que vous avez
cité vous avez repéré Aurélien Pradier
ouais il était tout jeune ouais il avait
il avait 16 ans il était impressionnant
Aurélien parce que à 16 ans il avait il
montré qu'il avait du potentiel ouais il
semblerait que ça n'it pas été démenti
alors vous avez aussi traversé au sein
des Jeunes Populaires des moments plus
difficiles notamment quand Nicolas
Sarkozi a a repris en main l'UMP il vous
a demandé de
démissionner c'est aussi ça
l'apprentissage de la politique c'est
c'est cet aspect qui peut être parfois
violent oui alors c'est pas exactement
qui il m'a pas exactement demandé de
démissionner j'étais j'ai il vous a
poussé à la démission on va dire on peut
le présenter comme ça en fait je savais
très bien qu'en me présentant à la
présidence des jeunes de l'UMP que j'ai
remporté à l'époque je savais très bien
qu'il était pas en soutien de ma
candidature et vous voyz comme trop pro
Jupé trop pro Chirac alors que c'était
pas forcément et pas assez pro Sarkozi
et c'était pas forcément faux mais
c'était pas forcément vrai non plus bon
bref quand quand on préside parti et
qu'on veut être candidat à la présidence
de la République on a envie d'avoir un
mouement de jeune qui obéit euh avec le
doigt sur la couture du pantalon l'enjeu
est tellement grand que je honnêtement
je le comprends je pense que on aurait
pu être géré différemment h c'est pas
grave on s'en fiche c'est passé
maintenant tout ça et et mais mais oui
on m'a présenté comme anti Sarkozi je
l'étais au fond pas pas à ce point donc
alors vous ça vous a pas empêcher de
continuer dans la politique dans des
cabinets ministériels au Conseil Général
des Yvelines et puis en 2016 vous avez
participé à la campagne d'alin
pour la primaire de la droite en 2017
laaffaire Fillon éclate et là entre les
deux tours de la présidentielle Vous
vous tournez vers Emmanuel Macron alors
pour bien resituer les choses dans le
contexte de l'époque faut faut se
rappeler qu'à l'époque à ce moment
précis il y avait pas mal de ralliments
à gauche mais encore assez peu à droite
ça a été une décision difficile à
prendre pour
vous oui et non non parce que par
rapport à beaucoup de mes amis qui
avaient des responsabilités politiques
qui avaient des mandats moi au fond je
n' engageais que moi-même donc je
n'avais pas grand-chose à justifier
auprès de ce n'était qu'un choix
personnel et et après oui c'était
difficile parce que parce que on était
pas nombreux à le faire et que quand
vous retournez vers vos amis qui
militent depuis 20 ans au même endroit
que vous et que et vous êtes seul bah
voilà vous vous dites bon bah j'aurais
préféré la politique c'est avant tout
une aventure collective on le dit pas
assez en tout cas moi c'est comme ça que
je le je le vis et et c'est vrai que
voilà ça a été ça un chis j'ai fait seul
passer peur de passer pour une traître
oui bien sû ça bien sûr bien sûr
c'est c'est c'est très compliqué de de
de de faire en sorte de faire comprendre
aux gens que on va pas à la gamelle en
fait on fait ça euh par conviction on
fait ça parce qu'on pense que c'est le
bon choix donc je pense que maintenant
les gens qui me connaissent et qui ont
pu juger de mon engagement depuis euh
savent ce qu'il en est mais mais sur le
moment il y a quand même ce premier
réflexe euh ce ce ce cette première ce
premier jugement qui est porté sur le
fait de la
trahison il y a une image de 2022 qui
qui m'a marqué c'est à la fin de la
cérémonie d'investiture d'Emmanuel
Macron à l'Élysée on le voit aller
saluer les principales personnalités
politiques qui sont présentes et puis à
un moment il s'arrête pour vous saluer
vous et pour vous remercier
personnellement de ce que vous avez fait
pour lui pendant la campagne
présidentielle et ça a surpris pas mal
de journalistes politiques comment vous
l'expliquez ah bah je sais pas peut-être
parce que je suis en dessous des radars
des journalistes polies c'est un peu
l'impression que ça donne c'estàdire que
tous les journ sont peut-être pas pris
la mesure du rôle que vous avez pu jouer
dans cette campagne peut-être moi mais
en plus je j'ai pas cherché à à le
valoriser particulièrement mais vous le
dites vous-même et pourquoi alors
pourquoi ne pas chercher à à vous mettre
un peu plus en avant parce que vous avez
occupé des fonctions toujours
importantes des postes de confiance vous
avez été secrétaire générale donc de la
campagne d'Alain Jupé en 2016 directrice
administrative et financière de celle de
François Fillon en 2017 trésorière de la
République en marche puis délégué
général
adjointe c'est des postes où on reste
dans l'ombre en général oui enfin moi je
je je je ne recherche pas la lumière
probablement que je la craignais aussi
hein donc voà et donc au fond c'est
quand même plus simple d'évoluer euh euh
dans l'ombre en tout cas c'est c'est
probement moins de pression donc euh
voilà
euh après j'essaie de faire sérieusement
mon travail de faire en sorte que les
gens qui me font confiance euh en soit
content et maintenant j'ai une dimension
euh je suis élu maintenant et donc je
sais qu'il y a une part euh d'exposition
que je dois aussi prendre parce que
c'est ce qu'on c'est ce qu'on attend
aussi de la fonction qui est la mienne
vous avez été élu première questeur de
l'Assemblée en 2022 au côté donc d'Eric
vert et d'Eric sootti c'est une fonction
stratégique de l'Assemblée on va en
parler dans un d'instant mais mais là
encore c'est une fonction qui est pas
très connue du grand public c'est un
rôle
euh fondamental hein alors sur le rôle
vous expliquez les questeurs sont à la
fois trésoriers et préfets alors on
parle souvent de ce cô côté trésorier
vous gérez un budget quand même très
conséquent ou combien c'est 600 millions
d'euros à peu près 600 millions d'euros
par an pour pour l'assemblée alors on
retient moins souvent le la dimension
préfet qu'est-ce que vous entendez par
là pour pour faire simple he les
questeurs ils s'occupent de l'exécution
de la définition et l'exécution du
budget il s'occupe d'accompagner le
personnel de l'Assemblée nationale c'est
quand même 1200 agents de la fonction
publique parlementaire et des
contractuel et il s'occupe d'accompagner
les députés dans les moyens qui sont les
leurs pour mener à bien leur le le
mandat donc c'est c'estes trois gros
morceaux si si je puis dire et et au
fond vous touchez un peu vous touchez un
peu à tous les domaine donc et donc
c'est peut-être c'est peut-être en ça
que une fonction de préfit un peu plus
préfit d'accord et alors vous dites que
Ker c'est un poste aussi voire plus
stratégique que secrétaire d'État ça
veut dire que si on vous poste si on
propose un poste de secrétaire d'État
vous direz non je vais pas me faire
beaucoup de copains avec secréta en
disant ça donc non mais c'est comme tout
Quest en tout cas c'est une
responsabilité très forte très important
dans l'institution euh on touche à
énormément de sujets donc là j'ai cité
les trois principaux sujets qui sont les
ressources humaines le budget et
l'accompagnement des députés mais en
réalité c'est il y en a beaucoup
d'autres parc bâtimentairire il y a les
investissements que l'on fait il y a la
démarche environnementale enfin bref il
y a beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de choses
ça ressemble à MRE d'une ville en fait
si on v le maire de
l'Assemblée on va passer à notre quiz à
présent je vous explique le le principe
je vais commencer une phrase et vous
allez devoir la compléter ouis on y va
depuis que je suis questeur beaucoup de
députés beaucoup de députés
euh font appel à moi pour pour les aider
dans l'exercice de leur mandat régler
des des petits des petits soucis oui
alors ça va de sujets compliqués à des
sujets moins compliqués de type
chauffage ou climatisation il faut
rester
humble les députés qui utilisent TikTok
WhatsApp ou Instagram essaie
d'intéresser les plus jeunes à leur
mandat ouais moi j'avais en tête ce
communiqué que vous avez publié avec les
deux autres questeurs en les invitant à
faire très attention à leurs données
personnelles ou tout fait sur leur
téléphone c'est tout à fait c'est vrai
qu'on a on on a voulu sensibiliser nos
collègues au fait que l'utilisation de
ces réseaux sociaux pouvait les exposer
euh et qu'il fallait être vigilant à
l'utilisation de l'ensemble des réseaux
sociaux par le biais des des des
téléphones portables qui sont qui sont
les leurs donc on peut pas leur
interdire de les utiliser mais ça
nécessite de la vigilance ou enfin quand
je ne serai plus député je pourrais
enfin euh oh là là faire plein de choses
la liste est longue elle est trop longue
non non mais il y a plein de choses que
que j'aimerais probablement plus faire
en premier lieu en premier lieu je
m'occuperai probablement plus de ma
famille voilà et après il y a plein
d'autres choses que que que j'aimerais
faire mais je suis honnêtement
euh une femme très épanouie dans la
façon dont je dont je gère mon temps à
la fois comme débutés comme de famille
et comme et comme individu et donc tout
va bien et ben ce sera le mot de la fin
merci beaucoup Marie gevnou d'être venu
dans la politique et moi
[Musique]
merci